i have these two images juxtaposed here
the i'm assuming
no audience that's at least familiar
with the hbo
version of game of thrones and then the
larger song of ice and fire and that's
the the throne that if you sit down and
cuts you that's the one that they're all
fighting
and then there's there's aristotle
looking rather dower and fairly marshall
there's a lot of images of him
and as i was um reading through
the the first book the one that's
already been adapted for hbo
i was i was very struck by many of the
sort of aristotelian
themes and framework when it came to
moral discourse when it came to talking
about
why people want to do things why
something is the best policy what's the
good all these sorts of things aristotle
provides a very
large dense overarching framework that i
think
when we teach aerosol often doesn't come
across
and a lot of this has to do with the the
sort of fragmentation of the discipline
so if you're studying aristotle in a
communications class you read the
rhetoric or perhaps the poetics if
you're reading them in a poli sci class
you read the politics if you're reading
them in a
philosophy class and it's a metaphysics
class you read the metaphysics perhaps a
few of the other works
if you're doing an ethics class you do
the nico mccann ethics but not the
eudaimian ethics
and aristotle's work is actually this
cohesive whole there's a lot of concepts
that are being explored
in one work that bear on another work
and i i noticed that so when i talk
about an overarching aristotelian
framework i'm talking about one that
draws from all of the ethical political
works
my original intent very often when you
when you do a conference proposal you
you
put out this promissory note and then
you realize
this just can't be done
and the reason why it can't be done for
this one has less to do with aristotle
and much more
with martin
what i was what i wanted to do was to
argue and i'm not actually going to
argue this here i'm just going to throw
out some ideas
that martin articulates a
neo-aristotelian view of human nature
characters development and of atheists
and moral qualities and the idea was to
reference a lot of you know provide a
lot of supporting detail and somehow
he's going to do this in 20 minutes
what i wanted to focus on in particular
was this notion of community as sharing
but also a locus of conflict
over moral qualities and judgments the
entirety of
the song of ice and fires we've seen it
so far and the five volume volumes that
we have
is of a society that's breaking down
ultimately that's if you had to do a
large picture
think and it's really about
what aristotle called stasis
or factions how we often translate it
i also want to look at the motivational
interplays between interests desires
loyalties and common goods in the
characters i want we look at ethos as
reflected in both individual characters
many of whom are exquisitely developed
and the houses that they they come from
and then i wanted to look at some of the
characters choices and developments as
matters of better worst practical
reasoning towards and about the variety
of human goods because it's interesting
nobody in in
these books says okay now it's time for
me to do some practical reasoning what
would aristotle say in this case instead
they do it and if you're a good
aristotelian you don't expect people to
to consult aristotle with this because
aristotle was writing about the way
that people in fact do practical
reasoning
now here's where the challenge comes in
this is where i bit off way more than i
that i could chew in this session
although i'm i'm now in the process of
putting together a bunch of notes that
i'm hoping will eventually turn into a
small book so martin's narrative sprawls
over entire continents this is the
westeros and as the books proceed you
get more and more places in it as well
at this point there's five over 800 page
volumes the later volumes just seem to
get thicker and thicker and thicker
which is suppose what you can do when
you're a well-established author you can
put up books as long as you like
there's
by one count there's over a thousand
characters that have been mentioned so
far now most of these are not
are not main characters but even if you
just counted up main characters and
there's disagreement about how you do
that
there's at least
you know it's in the double digits
just for main characters so it's very
different than
than you know looking at a a novel where
there's say three main characters
um it's interesting because uh guard
martin contrasts himself against tolkien
who he
says he's very influenced by it he saw
tolkien as an architect doing this kind
of world construction thing
and he sees himself as a gardener he
plants something and then he sees how
how it grows
he
thinks of his characters it seems as
sort of developing organically
within within the world and it's a very
morally complex and ambiguous narrative
and again i think this is where
aristotle can be somewhat illuminating
so
let's think about the aristotelian view
of character as we know about it
so aristotle thought that not only
ethics everyone gets this in their you
know required ethics course or intro to
philosophy course
and they learn about virtue ethics he
thought that not only ethics but also
politics rhetoric and poetics and he has
books titled after those ought to be
concerned with the character as a person
he thinks that if you're doing politics
and you're not concerned with character
there's something deficient he thinks
that if you're looking at
novels plays whatever and you're not
concerned with character there's
something deficient in the analysis
going on
there's four interlocking greek terms or
concepts that
fit into this notion of character one is
ethos the lasting character you might
think of it as the fabric of character
that's still nancy sherman's book title
about aristotle and
ethics
and then there's
ethos as a habitual disposition the
virtues and the vices fit in with that
there's you see this over and over and
over again running across aristotle's
body of work this concern with what he
calls topoio it's one of the categories
it's also
what
we're looking at in the poetics in a
particular person it's the how somebody
is
the how their actions are the how their
choices are how
they are and that tells us what they
they are this is this becomes part of
who they are and then
really key is what he calls pro-irasis a
term that you want to translate it very
literally it means
taking this before that so you can think
of it as preference or how you order
things and this is not something that
just happens in individual actions
pro-racist shows in that
it's something that forms a person's
character or expresses their character
over time and it involves some sort of
fundamental determinative choice so do i
you know
do i decide that wealth is really the
most important thing
uh and ignore my family when when
the demands of my family conflict with
wealth that would be part of my pro-eye
races
um do i
try to develop the virtue of courage how
do i understand encourage that would be
part of my my pro-erasions as well
these are all the things that fit into
what aristotle calls character so it's
what we do or
should do that don't
what we choose
and then here's where we get to the
moral discourse
we we talk about what we ought to do or
what other people want to do
or what they don't do and we we make
judgments on
it's how we approach situations
but not just situations how we approach
other people do we value them just
instrumentally do we see some sort of
intrinsic value in them
our actions
other people's actions even more
importantly temptations situations where
we're actually being tested that's what
pro-iracism
develops and shows itself
it has to do with what we value but not
only that how we rank order how we
prioritize how we
we make sacrifices between the variety
of goods that we have in our lives
and then what we deliberate about
and some people don't deliberate at all
that's that's going to be a problem
they're going to have a hard time
dealing with certain situations
how we deliberate what we bring into our
thinking about what we ought to do or
what we ought to say
is a sign of our character
so what does aristotle actually tell us
about character in the ethics the nico
mccain and the udayan ethics
he tells us that it's formed by choices
actions and not only those things but
also how we feel so there's a quote by
aristotle that's been used everywhere
it's the first line of emotion the book
emotional intelligence that it's not
easy to say
when it comes to anger
um when we should be angry with whom we
should be angry how much we should be
angry
and oftentimes we think of ethics just
in terms of humans actions aristotle and
the entire setillian tradition thinks of
it in terms of are we feeling the right
things at the right time for the right
reasons to the right degree
it centers on virtue advice habitual
dispositions deliberation and what you
might call
person formic choices
there are some choices that are
determinative who we become and you see
these choices being made in the song of
ice and fire by some of the important
characters
in the politics it gets more interesting
he tells us that any genuine community
involves character as a basis
and it fosters and recognizes good
character
a lot of what we
engage in
whether it was ancient greece or
contemporary politics are discussions
about what a community ought to look
like who want to rule
why
what a good person is what are we trying
to to form
aristotle recognizes this and then he
saw that communities are not only based
on relationships like say being in the
same family or owing fealty to somebody
but also on moral qualities on sharing
he says or agreement about the wall
qualities
in the rhetoric he says a character is
actually one of the most powerful and
important means of persuasion
he contrasts it against you know the
logos and pathos
um character also fits into the modes of
rhetoric aristotle those who are
familiar with his his
teachings about rhetoric or
communication know that he divides it up
into three basic types all of which
actually do have to do with character
even if it's forensic rhetoric which is
about the just and the unjust those are
qualities of a person
epidactic rhetoric is entirely about
character you're praising or censoring
or blaming yourself
finally in the in the poetics
which you might say that that applies
most to a literary work
character is a central component of
narrative
if you don't have developed character
you don't have a good narrative
aristotle says and how do we judge
character this is why i particularly
like martin because
as opposed to some some authors who just
you know want to show us things from
from the outside
he has all these characters
and he tells us what they're thinking
they go through these interior
monologues
they also have discussions with each
other
and we judge character by what people do
but even more by their expressed
thoughts and this is a category
called
the annoya he said this is also an
element of any drama and what thought
does is it reveals to us the
deliberation where the evaluations
people are making
these are the sorts of things that human
beings aristotle says
disagree about and agree about and share
in and
change their views on over time and
there's an entire range of moral
categories
some people are more motivated by these
than others and if you look at martin's
characters there are some people who are
motivated just by
concerns of pleasure and pain others
that are reducing everything to
usefulness for their
their
one drive that's that's orienting them
it doesn't necessarily have to be an
egoistic drug you can think of
in the
fifth book the growing importance of the
septums and
this sort of
very austere morality going along with
it that subordinates everything to
holiness
what is noble and what is base there's a
lot of discussion about in marvin i
think
and then finally you know the just and
the unjust not just
is a person just or unjust our social
arrangements just are unjust and there's
no radical critique like you know
there's going to be a marxist commune or
something like that because this is you
know
essentially medieval fantasy
milieu but there is a lot of discussion
about
what cons what constitutes justice and
should justice be sacrificed for
expediency
um
there's also a lot of moral ambiguity
recognized by aristotle and again i
think this doesn't get across when we
teach aristotle and ethics classes
in part because we're doing the survey
work
aristotle if you look at his his work
and especially if you read his histories
of things that are scattered throughout
the politics and then you know the
athenian constitution and other places
he sees that the same things can be
looked at many different ways
the politics is probably the work where
he's best about this he says you know
when it comes to these claims about who
who watch a rule or who is just or the
way things ought to be arranged these
people are partly right and here's why
they're also partly wrong
these people are partly right as well
and they're a bit more right than these
he oftentimes says nobody's completely
right
so there's moral ambiguity there
prime example um of this has to do with
you know rule worth or equality this
this
this uh
matrix for for strife and also for her
community and he noticed who does claims
on on getting to rule or getting to
determine things the rich
they have some legitimate
uh reason to want to rule
those of good family that's much more
important i think in martin's narrative
that it was in aristotle's time but if
you look at his works again you see this
coming up over and over again the
virtuous particularly the just because
justice is the virtue oriented towards
others and oriented towards one society
as a matter of fact aristotle says that
the other virtues can actually be looked
at in terms of justice so courage if
it's an individual circumstance it's
what i do say to protect my fiance when
you're about to be mugged if it has to
do with my going out on the battlefield
because that's the right thing to do for
my society that's a form of justice as
well as courage
then the free and the many these are all
people who have claims
and all these claims have some
legitimacy to them
where do we get into conflict according
to aristotle in political communities
one big conflict and again you see this
in martin's
work
some characters are very interested in
the common good
i would say that ned stark
is although he gets taken in i would say
that jon snow is a good example of that
daenerys is a great example of that as
well then there's others who are just in
it for whatever
egoistic ends they have um ruling for
for the self using rule to benefit
themselves and i'd say most of the
lannisters fit into that category
um
janoswint is a perfect example somebody
would sell anybody out or anything
then there's similarities we
the very fact that we're similar to each
other brings us into conflict and we can
have rivalries over all these things and
you see these emerging in there
aerosol lays out some key lines of
division between people so you might say
you're the type of character that you
have or the class that you have
will bring you into conflict with others
poverty he says though it's interesting
aristotle says the the greatest
difference is not between wealth and
poverty
it's between virtue advice
that the virtuous and the vicious will
always be in contact with each other
and what does this lead to is this
breakdown
faction within the political community
and what's really interesting about the
whole song of
ice and fire series
is you don't end up breaking down in
some sort of hobbesian war of all
against all
um
everybody wants to have
the seven kingdoms
unified prosperous working they just
want it under them for whoever it is
that they're supporting and when when
people engage in in faction they often
don't they're they're not in it just
there may be a few characters that you
could say like the mountain
all he likes to do is kill people in
horrible ways
or his brother
sandor who is so motivated by hate that
he would like to see the whole thing
fall down but most of them actually want
to
have some sort of cohesive political
community but they often have very
deficient ideas of what that consists of
there are some things there could be
some limitations to this i'm just going
to skip through this very quickly
aristotle didn't talk much about
religion because it wasn't a big issue
in his time
we see that becoming much more of an
issue
in the fourth and fifth book and i'm
very curious to see where it's going to
go in the sixth and seventh book he also
didn't write an awful lot about dynastic
politics which is what a lot of
the song of ice and fire was concerned
and he didn't think a lot about feudal
societies
in part because
those tended to be i mean you could say
that there were things sort of like
those but they tended to be outside of
the sphere of
the cultures that he was looking at
so what about martin's
well
you see a lot of similarities to aerosol
it recognizes a heterogeneity or
plurality of real and apparent goods
desires and motives and how do we know
this his characters talk about them
his characters act on them
he displays persons in terms of
character through their
their actions and their expressed
thoughts it's almost as if he's you know
consulted aristotle on how best to get
this across
he also and this is one of the things i
really like about his work he sets up
multiple moral interpretations not just
factual but moral evaluative
interpretations of the same event
or the person or the act or the decision
in words and thoughts of others and you
could think for example sometimes this
is a
crisis point you could think for example
about
jamie and kirsten's incest and the fact
that the
children
born of it who are ruling
are not legitimate children
stannis one of the
claimants to the throne
writes a letter about this other people
are talking about it there's there's a
key moment
in i forget whether it's a move i think
it's in the fifth book
where
their uncle
actually
he lets forth a remark as he's
dissociating from him this lannister
house is beginning to disintegrate
where you see that he now believes it
so
this is something very important i think
martin himself never takes a direct
moral position as an author he leaves it
up to you
to
sort of read into the characters and
listen to them and judge which is
actually better and which is actually
worse and again that's very ceterian
because aristotle himself he's got you
know this is better than that but he he
thinks that you can't just tell people
that and expect them to become good and
expect them to get it they have to see
it in
actions in the framework and some people
won't get a few minutes okay
martin's moral world is a very realistic
moral universe often disappointingly so
to some
the good is real but very vulnerable
requires protection and cultivation and
you see some people like ned stark
devoting time and attention to that
others
just exploiting it
martin has a has a habit of killing off
extremely well developed and likable
characters
and when it happens it's well and then
the quarrel hit him and he died
it's not you know very long drawn out
death scene or anything like that but
that's very realistic
the good is vulnerable
and becoming virtuous doesn't make you
involved
um good and evil are intermixed within
the characters and a lot of the
characters go through a struggle
especially in their deliberation about
are there better sides of their worst
sides going to predominate
and there's there's a you know real
tipping point for some of these the
characters develop more like
some of them
they deliberate they follow up the wall
of choice
i'm going to actually close with this i
have i have some other slides where i
look at some of the characters
themselves
and
some of the things that they're saying
but you know we can talk about that
later there's an interesting vlog
medieval robots and i came across this
one a while ago and they were saying
that martin is writing a historical
chronicle and this was seen as kind of a
bad thing because you know he's
interested mainly in the elite and i
give you some some examples of this
in the article itself they said the most
interesting characters are the ones who
are part of the elite but are not
exactly an accepted part so tyrion
lannister
aria stark
daenerys jon snow
the characters who aren't well born
they're supporting characters but
they're not really
explored in great detail for the most
part
and i think that this is actually on
track i think that
martin is not trying to ride in every
man's
vast
novel landscape he is focusing on those
and this is another reason why i think
aristotle could be particularly useful
in analyzing this
because the concerns of persons are
caught within agonistic aristotelian
framework that's concerned with rural
houses
and political community
i go through a bunch of
discussions of
of
that these are the all the houses at
least most of the ones you can go on and
find lots of nice you know pretty
pictures of them
this is what i'm going to close with you
notice that all of them have have words
they call these their words this is part
of what forms their moral discourse
how stark winter is coming how stark
exists primarily as the protectors of
the north that forms their their ethos
lannister uh hear me roar the lion as
being sort of this this dangerous vain
creature
um not particularly concerned with the
public concern with the good of that
that house
house tully i'm not sure if you can make
it out too well
is family duty honor and you see that
reflected in these characters house
greyjoy are these uh essentially modeled
after the blankets we do not sew they
are the ones who go out and
take over anybody who happens to be weak
these are all parts of ethos
so that's where i'm going to leave them
off and
if you haven't read all these books i
didn't want to give any spoilers i hope
i didn't
so thanks